am samstag bin ich in ein restaurant
gegangen gemeinsam mit meinem verlobten
und wir wollten dort essen und dann
wurde nach meinem ausweis gefragt zum
drinnen sitzen da habe ich gesagt ja den
habe ich auch mit abitur bezahlt haben
sie gesagt ja sie müssen auch keine
maske tragen wir haben hier jetzt 2g 3g
bedeutet also noch genesene und gifte in
dieses restaurant dürfen dasselbe ist
mir auch schon vor zwei wochen im
friseursalon passiert wo ich meine haare
blondieren lassen immer wieder also
passiert ist mir der sich ein orte bin
wo ich nur noch als geimpfte reinkomme
beim friseursalon konnte ich nicht nein
sagen weil ich brauchte neue streben das
restaurant habe ich jedoch verlassen ich
möchte nicht in einer gesellschaft leben
in der ich nicht gemeinsam auch mit
freunden familien kann sie sich
vielleicht nicht wie ich haben impfen
lassen ich möchte nicht in einer
gesellschaft leben in der es geimpft und
ungeimpft gibt in denen ungeimpfter in
anderen status als ich als geimpfte
haben warum können sie sich nicht testen
lassen auch in das restaurant mit mir
gehen ich möchte mehr solidarität für
die ungeimpften und ich möchte dass
geimpfte in deutschland auch sagen
können nein ich habe mich noch nicht
prüfen lassen ohne soziale ächtung in
kauf nehmen zu müssen es muss endlich
aufhören dass wir menschen in zwei
klassen einteilen das darf nicht sein
und jedem restaurant besitzer der das
macht mit den zweig es wird viele kunden
haben aber mich nicht ich habe mich
entschlossen in der zukunft restaurants
zu boykottieren die zweige regelung
umsetzen und ich bin geimpft das muss
man immer dazu sagen tut mir leid nach
deiner freundlichen einladung hier
gleich brachial sein gretchen zu müssen
aber ich sehe es glaube ich gleich auf
mehreren ebenen anders als das eine ist
ja was macht der einzelne gastronomen
und da muss ich sagen habe ich volles
verständnis dafür wenn jemand sagt ich
werde jetzt diese zweig regel an einfach
weil es für ihn möglicherweise eine
wirtschaftliche notwendigkeit sein kann
ja also die alle hatten erhebliche
einnahmeausfälle in den letzten
anderthalb jahren und jetzt ist es halt
du kannst mehr gäste empfangen wenn du
diese zweige regeln anwendet und es ist
natürlich für deine gäste möglicherweise
auch einfach attraktiver nun ist es zeit
eine auszeichnung für dich die müssen
dann nicht mehr die maske tragen wenn
sie von tisch zu tisch gehen derzeit das
finde ich also einfach sehr
nachvollziehbar da trifft glaube ich die
falschen wenn man sagt solche
restaurants boykottiert man jetzt die
andere frage ist natürlich politisch
findet man das gut dass überhaupt seine
anreizstruktur geschaffen wird für die
einzelnen gastronomen das zu und da ja
ja sag ich mal kann man so und so sehen
ich persönlich glaube dass das mit dem
anreiz schiefgegangen ist also
wahrscheinlich hat der eine oder andere
sich gedacht dass ein anreiz für die
gastronomen es ist aber gar keinen
anreiz für die gastronomen sondern eine
bestrafung derer die sozusagen sich
irgendwann lassen wollen und das ist
mein problem mit der mit der regelung
ich habe gar nicht so sehr das konkrete
im blick das soll jeder selber
entscheiden boykottiert andere gehen hin
ist ja sowieso eigentlich gut immer mal
wieder daran zu erinnern dass jeder
möglich selber entscheiden können soll
was er macht das können aber ungeimpfte
sozusagen in vielen lebensbereichen
jetzt nicht mehr und sie waren schief
angeguckt und ich glaube dass wir wenn
wir nicht sehr stark aufpassen und die
regierung hat mit dieser verordnung und
gesetzgebung die grundlage geschaffen
dass wir wirklich so klima kriegen
können dass du ungeimpfter so eine art
schimpfwort ist also dass ich leute
anfangen zu fragen die neben uns die
nachbarn ich glaube das sind zwei
ungeimpfte oder dass man sich die frage
stellt kann ich meine kinder eigentlich
zu dem kindergeburtstag schicken die
eltern sind ungeimpft hatte schon gehört
ungeimpfte leben wahrscheinlich mit
ungeimpften unter einem dach das macht
mir wirklich so ein gemisch das
düstere düstere zeiten ich glaube das
ist uns als restaurantbesuche
möglicherweise zu kommt nicht durch den
boykott und die stetigen der gastronomen
sozusagen ein zeichen zu setzen sondern
laut und deutlich zu akzentuieren dass
die regierung hier rahmenbedingungen
geschaffen hat die eine zwei klassen
gesellschaft
ich finde also im friseursalon war ich
ja schon geschockt das haben wir schon
letzte woche zum besten gegeben hat mir
das okay das heißt langjährige kunden
wie diesem friseur jetzt über 30 jahre
20 jahre die treue gehalten haben die
empfängt der friseur jetzt nicht mehr
weil man umgeben ja nein nein nein mach
ich nicht ich konnte heute nur an dem
tag keine möglichkeit also immer dunkler
und dunkler nicht irgendwer ist ein
friseur wo ich wieder mit maske sitzen
werde auch wenn ich die maske hasse wie
beweist aber ich werde mir jetzt einen
friseur sowie dem geschätzt nie mehr
eine euro fix
ich habe ja ein riesiges dilemma klar
wir sind also du hast auch schon sagt
menschen aus der presse habe ich halte
lieber den ungeimpften und werde ins 3g
friseursalon mit der maske gehen aber
ich finde dieses im restaurant die
umgehen müssen jetzt draußen bleiben das
fand ich wirklich in dem moment
schockierend und deswegen sage ich der
gastronom soll menschen willkommen
heißen diese zweiklassengesellschaft von
der du sprichst klaus ich glaub das ist
ein ganz wichtiger punkt und mich würde
mal interessieren wie wolfgang bosbach
das aussieht aber ich glaube das wäre
ein super beispiel haben wie es auch
anders geht das ist das nördliche
nachbarland von deutschland von
schleswig-holstein dass es dänemark in
dänemark gibt es gar keine regeln mehr
was corona angeht und in dänemark ist
corona auch nicht mehr die große und
gefährliche pandemie und natürlich ist
das virus gefährlich in dänemark ist
kona eine gefährliche krankheit und das
leben hat sich da doch sehr sehr stark
normalisiert obwohl die impfquote in
dänemark jetzt gar nicht so dramatisch
besser ist als in deutschland also ich
glaube und das wäre auch die frage
glauben sie ja bosbach
reagiert die deutsche politik oder sie
hat auch glaube ich dramatisch
überreagiert politiker haben generell
ein interesse dinge zu regeln für den
bürger zu regeln weil die dame immer
dokumentieren müssen ja ich tue ja was
ich mache ja was ein politiker ist ja
ständig unter rechtfertigungsdruck und
muss immer wieder auch beweisen dass er
zu recht für irgendetwas gewählt wurde
dieses zweig zeigt ja eigentlich wieder
nur das etwas geregelt wird was bürger
möglicherweise gar nicht mehr brauchen
als regelt die dänen machen es uns vor
oder liege ich mit der these politiker
müssen alles regeln falls jedenfalls
steil die these ist die zeitliche
abfolge ist in friseur kann ich nicht so
sagen ich habe noch nie die haare blond
einbauen lassen alles vom lieben gott
als natur restaurant ist die private
entscheidung des gastronomen und wenn
sie mal die dehoga fragen ein buntes
bild die einen sind dafür die anderen
sind dagegen das ist die private
entscheidung des als lustig so wie es
mal vorsichtig so wie es ihre
entscheidung auch ist ob sie das angebot
jetzt annehmen oder nicht oder ob sie so
habe ich das verstanden als geimpfte
solidarisch mit den umkämpfen das was
natürlich hohe wellen schlägt ist der
fußball ein verein erster fc köln da
geht es ja um
zehntausende hat sich für 2g entschieden
es gab kritik aber weit überwiegend
zustimmung ob das durchgehalten werden
kann ist eine andere frage wir haben ja
auch noch einen langsamen im fortschritt
ist auch die frage wie lange wird es
noch dabei bleiben wir haben am anfang
die bilder aus bergamo gehabt wo sich
die särge gestartet haben wir haben die
bilder aus new york gehabt ist doch klar
dass die politik dann gesagt hat gürtel
und hosenträger älter
safety first oberziel war immer keine
überlastung unseres gesundheitssystems
keine kritische und wir haben das
eigentlich besser gemeistert als die
meisten anderen staaten um uns herum
aber jetzt sind wir in einem stadium wo
man sagen kann andere machen doch vor
dass es gehen auch das warum stehen
werden auch auf der bremse ist das der
punkt aber das ist ja glaub ich
entscheidend bei dem was du auch sagst
also man kann immer in die vergangenheit
schauen beim thema berger muss auch
nicht ganz klar wie diese dramatischen
zahlen wir können sie stande gekommen
sind das muss man auch bei allen thesen
sind jetzt in diesen tagen eine
bundestagswahl gegeben wer schon vor
vier wochen der freedom day gekommen
zu sagen wir machen am 31 oktober
frieden ohne zu wissen wie dann die lage
ist normal also auch diese ungerne
friesoythe dieser gute sozusagen
gutbürgerliche grundsatz vorsicht ist
die mutter der porzellankiste heißt es
glaube ich
war sozusagen besonders ausgeprägt wegen
dieses weil datums keiner wollte mit
einem vorstoss oder mit der
verantwortungsübernahme kurz vor der
wahl in die situation kommen
tote irgendwie verantworten zu müssen
selbst wenn sie gar nicht existieren
sondern nur möglicherweise kommen können
und ich glaube dass diese dieses
wahldatum hat uns sozusagen in den
herbst gebracht und jetzt in eine
gemutmaßt neue welle von der ich auch
länger nichts mehr gehört hat also die
irgendwie nicht so richtige ausmaße
erreicht und ich glaube dass jetzt das
in diesen koalitionsverhandlungen und so
die immer noch nicht sozusagen den punkt
gibt also sagen wir lösen jetzt mal die
bremse ich habe im moment eine andere
sorge auch in einem punkt entgegenkommen
wenn der staat etwas anbietet geht es
gar nicht mit 2 gb öffentlichen
einrichtungen ich habe die dinge
wirklich politische und
gesellschaftliche sorge dass wir
mittlerweile ein ausnahmezustand zur
regel erklären und derjenige der von
seinem grund und bürgerrechten
gebrauchen muss der ist jetzt nachweis
wichtig dass eine antwort wir haben es
ganz still leise ist und sich umgedreht
genau nach letzte statement von der
konzentrieren weil du immer als schlecht
also ich teile die sorge durchaus auch
generell so ein bisschen was das
zerfallen der gesellschaft angeht in
geimpften und ungeimpften und die
vorbehalte die es da so gibt aber
gleichzeitig muss man nicht ich bin ja
wirklich eigentlich sehr freiheitlich
denkende mensch über dieses sehr starke
solidarität bedürfen ist dass du
formuliert das thema das hab ich
zumindest nicht in dem ausmaß weil ich
schon denke wir haben ja nun mal in
allen möglichen lebensbereichen ständig
freiheitseinschränkung ist doch immer
eine frage von kosten und nutzen und in
diesem fall scheint mir einfach die
kosten also sich impfen zu lassen sind
wirklich nicht besonders hoch aber soll
man treibt sie immer mehr in die höhe
weil man sich irgendwie einredet die
impfung sei mit mikrochips durchsetzt
oder sonst irgend welchen schwachsinn
und der nutzen ist schon beträchtlich ja
ok dänemark zeigt dass es zumindest
momentan offenbar auch ohne geht und in
dem fall würde ich auch sagen machen das
gerne wie dänemark aber trotzdem ist zum
thema also so richtig leidenschaftlich
kann ich da nicht werden bei der
verteidigung des rechts sich nicht
impfen zu lassen
[Musik]